son los olvidados de la guerra en
ucrania
todos los días adultos mayores llegan a
los refugios de vinito estos centros
tienen poco personal y suministros aquí
se encuentran sin medicación para sus
enfermedades crónicas necesitan ayuda
especializada que muchas veces no está
disponible
en estas instalaciones hay más de 130
residentes el 60% son personas de la
tercera edad la infraestructura
anteriormente era una maternidad
abandonada fue reabierta en marzo para
albergar temporalmente a los desplazados
internos todos los trabajadores son
voluntarios alguien tenía que hacerlo
conocemos este trabajo y cómo organizar
todo correctamente
julia no con la hiena de 83 años llegó
hace semanas huyó de su departamento en
lysychansk ya no podía salir por los
bombardeos
si hubiera tenido un pariente cercano
que viviera conmigo me hubiera quedado
prestaba sola por eso tuve que irme la
gran mayoría de adultos mayores
desplazados por la guerra se encuentran
solos solo algunos tienen la suerte de
ser recogidos de estos centros por sus
parientes según las autoridades
ucranianas más de 13.000 personas
mayores o discapacitadas se encuentran
en la región de diámetro y más de medio
millón ha pasado por la ciudad desde el
inicio del conflicto el 24 de febrero